There are all sorts of different ways to view the world. Here are three, a
fish-eye lens, a perspective view and an orthographic view. These are all
different types of projections. A projection maps locations in the world to
locations on the screen. A fish-eye projection is possible to simulate in
computer graphics. Hey, just about anything can be simulated in computer
graphics, but it's rarely used in practice. These other two projections are
more popular for a number of reasons. First they act similarly to a how a
camera captures a picture. So we're used to them. Straight lines stay straight
unlike a fisheye lense. All in all the math is simpler. A perspective view
we'll usually associate with seeing the world. Distant objects get smaller. An
orthographic view is much more common in design software. In an orthographic
view objects do not get smaller as they get more distant. Parallel lines in the
real world stay parallel in this kind of view as opposed to perspective where
they do not.